welcome back to CBS this morning it's
time for what we call talk of the table
you know the one where we each pick a
story that we like and we share with all
of you and with each other guys I don't
think this has ever happened before
because for the first time we all have
the same talk at the table I think
that's very cool why because we're
celebrating an anniversary I think I
like I know imagine that it has been one
year ago today one year ago today since
you first saw me Anthony and Tony's
sitting at the table all together we
took a class picture and everything and
boy what a year it has been for all of
us so first we want to take a look back
at some of the memorable moments and the
fascinating people that we've enjoyed
bringing you from the studio and now
from our house to yours rotate YouTube
from somewhere I'm excited for us it's
our game day I think it could be Wow Wow
Wow we the best music be the best news
welcome this really is the room where it
happens it looks pretty grand it's got a
two-step process people line up for
coffee at places like this and then
they're gonna be lining up at polling
stations that is one sensational week in
American politics impeachment
proceedings wrap up with a final vote
this is what the end result is
you have a 20-something year old
daughter would you allow her to be alone
definitely not with our Kelly I wouldn't
leave my daughter with anybody that's
accused of pedophilia
that's what Gillan and Jeffrey did they
took away the thing I was supposed to do
and they did that to everybody I want to
say to the witnesses thank you for
testifying justice will prevail
people say jewel is toxic is it the
product or the company interesting that
you would there's no rule or regulation
that says you as a hospital you cannot
charge ten thousand dollars for X in
such a big process like this when we
need to think outside the box you can
actually see our own CBS News team
getting temperature check right off the
plane we're all susceptible because this
is a new virus and it's virus while it's
tearing us apart in some ways is also
pulling us together
[Applause]
CBS this morning we're calling it stop
the stigma a conversation about mental
health and you are braver than you
believe stronger than you seem and
smarter than you think how does it feel
to come back there Jay I never figured
I'd be even living this long 96 years
old is not chicken feed tonight that
ladies and gentlemen is a Saturn 1b
rocket welcome to the Empire State
Building Wow
I am at the same level as that
helicopter right there can you make it
blue and yellow for CBS this morning of
course he can
well it's not Venice but it's Venice
look you know me mr. mayor what are
three words that would best describe you
standing near Liz oh right and I said
what does Rascal Flatts means it
traveled all around the world and you
can get right where you started ten
minutes from my house nice he absolutely
embarrassed me on national TV
Paddington Bear teddy bear teddy bear
his middle name is bear and the Oscar
for best morning show segment goes to
you're gonna do a little Carlton dance
with me you're embarrassing yourself all
the people that didn't participate I'm
gonna remember y'all
[Music]
we have done a lot we have done a lot in
a year I think it's time for breakfast
cake I think I think it's time for
breakfast cake all right
mine is German chocolate there it is -
German chocolate chocolate torturing my
wife been sitting in the fridge for a
Jay now tantalizing us we are ready go
on Gail go on I know it's great
but you know what guys when I think
about the past year normally you say boy
the year flew by but for me for this
year it was flying by and then we hit
Corona and then it's like her and now I
can't believe that that I can't really
believe that it's been a year a lot has
happened to us in a year Tony what are
you thinking yeah I know it has been an
incredible year if you had told me one
year ago that at the end of a 12-month
period I'd be doing the show from my
home I would have assumed I'm not doing
the show anymore feels like everything
went wonderfully right I had to work
friends who become my work husband and
wife and it's it's been a lovely Union
and the best part about it I think maybe
now because we're working from home we
all have our own bathroom and we all
know that's the key to a happy marriage
professional where all of us are from
home we're the only morning show Anthony
you notice too that we're all working
from our homes and that says a lot this
is difficult to do but the team we have
we pull it off every day and I'm proud
I'm proud to be working with you guys
Anthony that thanks Gil and and that's
what I wanted to say the team behind us
has been you know where the face is in
front but we've had an extraordinary
team behind us and they've really showed
their strength in the last couple of
months trying to do what we're doing
right now which is not easy I can tell
you it's hard enough on a regular day
but broadcasting from home and you give
all that they've really risen to the
challenge it's extraordinary